je pense que donald trump avec la faire
qu'un léger l'éthique acquis maintenant
et est publique et une très très bien
placé pour le mans le chef d'état le
mieux placé au monde pour réaliser à
quel point ces applications sociales
peuvent être utilisés à des fins de
manipulation d'opinion publique tant que
toutes ces applications sociales étaient
américaines la nation américaine pouvait
s'estimer relativement sécurisé bien que
cabu génétique a quand même causé
beaucoup de problèmes
on a mené entre eux pour pouvoir mais là
si on en arrive à un stade où les
chinois ont un contrôle d'une façon
d'une autre une capacité à manipuler
l'opinion publique américaine où les
jeunes américains effectivement on peut
comprendre que le président des états
unis soit a terrifié par cette
perspective tout ça s'exprime de façon à
dire trump yens mais la crainte est
vraiment légitime et que qu'est ce que
vous a retardé par manipuler les les
adolescents américains
comment cette application peut-elle
manipuler mais adolescents américains
pour aucun but génétique a comme jessica
nous a montré qu'on était capable avec
ce genre d'applicatifs de saisir la
psychologie tout un chacun d'adapter un
message adapté à tout un chacun pour le
faire basculer typiquement dans d un
vote d'abstention dans le cadre comme
j'ai été cas où un vote en faveur de
trump on peut imaginer faire ce genre de
manipulation à tout un tas d'autres fins
si on a vraiment si on commence vraiment
à utiliser ce type d'applicatifs pour
manipuler les esprits thème du handicap
vraiment montré que c'était une piste
tout à fait envisageable est très
vraisemblablement efficace si demain une
nation étrangère pénètrent sur le sol
américain et prend tout en partie le
contrôle de l'opinion publique ou de
certaines émotions collectives de
l'adolescence des adolescents américains
on est très clairement face à un danger
on a une nation étrangère qui peut
susciter tel ou tel sentiment au sein de
sa jeunesse c'est vraiment
potentiellement très dangereux
[Musique]